and speaking of the right thing to do
this man is an idol of mine I've loved
watching him play and he's just stands
for all that is is great and right and
not just in the golf world
I saw his message that he tweeted out
for everybody to be safe and be smart to
try and battle the coronavirus and I
guess he also would love to chat some
NFL free agency and why not we all love
the sport he's one of the all-time
greats and the Golf Hall of Fame as well
as in business he's Jack Nicklaus how
are you sir I'm better for talking to
you thank you for calling in I saw your
message I saw your message and it really
blew me away jack about what you wanted
to say to keep people certainly if your
generation is safe and sound I'd love
for you to repeat it or just tell
anybody who might not have seen your
message on your Twitter accounts and
your social media feeds well you know in
general I basically said that I sort of
applauded the sports world and what they
did I thought they made the right
decisions and also that you know we had
we have problems and we problem czar
going to be around for a while and that
you know I said I'm I'm 80 years old my
wife's 80 years old
we're both at-risk people and that but
the kids you know are not going to be if
the kids got to be smart because they're
gonna take it over to their parents and
their grandparents and we've just got at
a time when we all going to be smart we
got to be trying to stay healthy we try
to do the things that the government is
asking us to do and if we do that we'll
get through this thing I like we always
do would you mind letting people know
what what precautions you and your wife
are taking obviously you have a large
family and a large extended family that
you've let America essentially in on
getting to know throughout the decades
how are you handling this personally
Jack well I'm just sort of basically
staying at home I end up having a cold
last week so I don't know it Barbara die
that we got tested for it but we don't
we won't have the results back for a
couple days but I'm feeling I'm feeling
fine now but I think that we basically
stayed over I've been home
in the house here for I guess five days
now and I haven't really been anywhere I
haven't tried to I've kept the kids away
we had a birthday last night and one of
the kids I did to go to it and I just
don't think it's smart I think it's I
think we all guys there's a lot of
things I don't want to I get 20 22
grandkids and they're all going to keep
coming up with birthdays and functions
as much as I want to go to them I think
right now we just sort of you know call
him give him a hug over the phone and
say have a great day Jack Nicklaus here
on the Rich Eisen show where you party
it all into the decision by those at
Augusta National to postpone the the
Masters were you involved in that
conversation at all involved in the
conversation Fred called me before him
before he announced it told me what he
was going to do and I concurred with him
I thought I thought that was the right
right call for him and you know I and
people have said well they're gonna try
to play the Masters later I don't I
don't know how they can I don't know
they can get it get it on the schedule I
think it would be great if they could
but you know that would be probably
unfair to another another tournament
yeah I guess you know there there's a
whole reconfiguring of the sports world
right now and the conversation might be
that the Masters would be played in
September I imagine you've played that
course in September does it play any
differently at that time of year nobody
never played it in September it's it
doesn't open until October 15th okay so
literally nobody has ever set foot on
that course in the month of September is
what you're saying jack and that's
probably somebody local and that just
went out and hit balls but basically the
golf course is closed from May 15th
October 15th and then they overseed the
golf course and the fall the golf course
is not really very good because it's at
work the rye grass growing in the greens
will be all right but you know it would
be it would be a difficult thing to do
and whether they do it or not I don't
know but if they did I think it'd be
great but I think that's what do you do
with every other tournament to sit
date right Jack Nicholas here on the
Rich Eisen show I'm part of you know I'm
glad that you you know I'm not very
well-versed on the Augusta National
openings in close so I appreciate you
you chiming in on that so are you are
you watching the NFL news that's that's
coming across the screen a little bit
here and there and seeing the things and
first I've got a grandson said free
agents right now I don't think they
could be me up very high but he's been
working hard trying to get himself from
quicker and faster and right you know
hopefully somebody's got a somebody's
got to pick up somebody that's pretty
good he's gonna be a lot better now than
he was but anyway I've been watching it
and we're following it and I'm very
interested in seeing things boy I tell
you did
Arizona get a deal they sure did I mean
what what you think of that DeAndre
Hopkins straight huh Wow I mean is he
some receiver I mean I don't know about
Johnson but I would I would I'm
surprised it would ever let Hopkins go
it is it was kind of surprising what did
you think of Tom Brady's decision to
announce today to part ways with the
Patriots for 20 years and you know I
think Tom still wants to play I do not
have never met Tom so I don't know it's
that right know everybody well you know
he's a Michigan guy you know we don't
get together
I'm a big Brady fan I really haven't I
been a big Brady fan for a long time and
I think he handled himself beautifully I
I'm disappointed that the patients don't
want to move on with him but you know
that's their business and not mine but
it's a what a what a talent and he's not
done yet did you ever think of playing
football back in the day Jack oh I
played but I was you know I I could only
because they started right into golf
season and sure I I was smart enough to
figure out that I played quarterback I
wasn't tall enough my hands weren't big
enough and you know it's just it was
just it made more sense for me to play
golf but it didn't play football so
that's what I did so
where were you there of course you were
what was your relationship with Woody
Hayes back in the day Jeff had a great
relationship with Woody Hayes Woody's
was one of my favorite people you know
he was it was fabulous to deal with
people don't realize that woody and I
could be a little off this but I think
everybody was what he salary what he
took the job on my estate was 25,000
when he retired he was 25,000 what he
never took a raise he always put his
money back into the program or into kids
and he was a very highly principled guy
I mean he had he had a little he had a
little trouble sometimes on Saturday but
for the most part Woody Hayes is one of
the one of the great people of I've ever
met so are you saying you didn't you
didn't stay in touch with Bo
Schembechler then because he was a
Michigan guy jack is a no and I came
very good friends and Bo used to come
every time I played up in Detroit Bo
would come out and walk with me and we
talk all the time well III when I went
to the I you know I'm a Michigan man
myself
Jack full disclosure yes but but you
know the great Michigan Golf Course
right in the shadow of Michigan Stadium
there were always legends about how you
played and what you did on this hole
what you did on that hole and how you
dominated this course in that way is it
true that that course is also designed
or some of the courses some of the holes
designed by the same masters designer
Dustin national is that a chance
Mackenzie did did the University of
Michigan he then I estate University and
he did a destination oh absolutely
okay your favorite hole at Augusta
National would be what Jack which is the
one oh I don't know I think that
probably I like them all I always RC
when I'm playing at the time but I mean
I love I love the Amen Corner I love 12
I love 13 and I think that that area
right there is pretty special at Augusta
what about 16 I mean would that be one
that you'd mentioned as well I've had
great success at 16 and I've read a lot
of times when coming down to the end and
it's been very good to me but I don't
think 16 is they got nearly the
excitement that that 12 has is it true
that on that on that 16 in your famed
masters in 86 that you hit the ball and
and it was said I hope the club is right
I hope it's there and you picked up your
tea and not even looking saying it is is
that a true story yeah I hit that I
couldn't see the bottom of the flag
there's a bunker that sat in front of
the where the hole was but anyway I hit
a 5-iron it was a little breeze in our
face and the ball was in the air and I
hit it just exactly where I wanted to of
my sudden Jacky was caddying for me good
be right and I just looked up up looked
at anybody says it is and that's the
cockiest remark I've ever made could
have gone anywhere I know that's gotta
that's that's just awesome all right
before I before I let you go Jack
one more time please for anybody out
there that needs to know I don't know if
you've seen there's there's videos of
people going to beaches there's people
who are still frequenting and large
audiences in large crowds right now I'm
trying my best to tell everybody about
it and I'm one just I'd give you the
floor one more time jack on that said I
don't think you can shut your life down
I think you did I think I think outdoors
is fine you know if you want to go play
golf I think you don't have to be in a
crowd to play golf or you don't have if
you want to go out in a in a boater you
want to go you know work out outside
take a run I don't think that's any
problem the problem is is gathering and
keep them clean you got to wash your
hands and you can't be coughing on
somebody and you gotta say the kids have
got to be respectful of other people
because they may get it and not even
know it
and all of a sudden take it home to the
mom or pop or grandpa or grandma and all
of a sudden they've got a problem so I
think we just need to be smart and think
about where we're going what we're doing
and we'll get through this thing as I
said Americans as Americans we need to
work together and we'll get through it
Jack you are
you're the man and I genuinely
appreciate you taking some time out of
your day to make this phone call it
means a lot to the show and everybody on
it and everybody listening and watching
so thank you and be well well thanks for
separation is nice talking with right
back at you that's Jack Nicholas right
here in the Rich Eisen show